good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy wetness
day it is our favorite day here at the
toast it is hump day middle of the week
Shenanigans and speaking of girls who I
believe got humped
it is my pregnant
sister and co-host yeah that's right
pregnant
Jax hey Jax what's going on hey turdy
Lou Who uh
not much
just yeah being pregnant we announced
turdy and I announced our news yes we're
very excited about this next chapter we
are
um now I posted on my Instagram
yesterday that I'm pregnant we dropped a
patreon episode with all the Deets how
I'm feeling the gender the gender what's
been going on how turdies feeling what
this means for turdy how turdy's kind of
being pushed out how tourney's being
pushed out but also how this is great
for turdy as well yeah no it's so true
there's so many benefits for antelatered
and that's really all you can ask from a
sister from a turd
so now that you like
um are out and about you said something
to me like I don't even think on the
podcast just like in life about how
being pregnant in the first trimester is
so hard because you feel the worst but
you also can't tell anyone yeah so
complain girly it's like the last few
months these days I am feeling better
but the last few months like
I would want to say like I'm tired we're
I don't feel well or something and or
what did I do yesterday affecting
nothing because I was so fatigued and
couldn't move yeah
um that's when you want to like share
and kind of complain but you can and
then now I am feeling a little better
and I'm like what's everyone chatting
about yeah right what's going on guys
what's the hot what's the 4-1-1 what's
everybody talking about yes so um I am
I'm feeling better in the second
trimester the first especially the first
two weeks were rough like just so so so
tired like depleted Beyond
um I talk about in the patreon like you
know what I did mostly eating healthier
unfortunately helped a lot I know so
lame and not lame disappointed I know
because you think you're pregnant like
let's Scourge yeah right
but no then you feel like absolute
garbage so just you know smaller meals
more frequently which is what they say
you know I just never actually ingested
that information it's so annoying when
they are right you know when it's like
sure I could eat small meals frequently
but why not just one big one and not
have to think about it for a few hours
that's pretty much the philosophy I've
subscribed to for most of my life but
I'll be thinking about something else if
I do that which is how awful I feel so
small meals it is so you might feel
awful but the toast always always makes
you feel better is that like a proven
pregnancy like kind of doctor approved
thing that you have going on yeah it's
definitely it's nice to have
distractions
the toast oh so that's all we are to you
yeah just a side piece a distraction
that's all you are to me turdy
I'm kidding you're my mean you're my
main squeeze speaking of turdy today we
have deer toasters and two things one we
have an update that will literally bring
a tear to your eye it's so beautiful
it's so beautiful it sounds like a lie
okay that's how beautiful it is that's a
fantastic check we're gonna need to um
check on that and then two it's so funny
how turdy has taken on such a life of
its own when people have been writing in
recently people always love to you know
talk about their friends or husbands and
they obviously won't say their real name
so they'll always come up with a fake
name like Theo Bruno Harry rolled
um everyone is naming their significant
others turdy
there are significant others wow
yeah turdies kind of like wildfire
that's the impact turdy has had it's
impactful
it is I mean someone's being a mother
which you can hear all about Jackie's
journey to Motherhood number two on the
patreon patreon.com toast it is a video
and audio podcast you can watch or you
can listen and we're talking about it
all we're mentioning it all you know
Jackie having sex BBT the gender
motherhood being pregnant with a
one-year-old all of that BBT different
from the BBC
but
is it BBC
BBC greater than BBT
definitely I don't know BBT can create
life
so can BBC
depends which BBC definition you're
thinking of but if you think of the one
I'm thinking of could definitely create
life yeah so that's just something you
need to think about today to ponder just
yeah that's what we're always doing here
at the toast giving you thought
provoking thoughts like who's everyone's
celebrity doppelganger
a wench I hate it I just like can't get
over that that was your question at the
at the table
well get over it because it was
okay fine I won't continue as it was it
won't continue on good as to why it
makes no sense
so
what was I gonna say oh just like a
quick update for me last night I'm still
home alone
and I almost feel like I'm pregnant
because I remember you would not be
literally making everything about me
literally everything is about 30 but
it's fine because I'm kind of like I'm
fit to eat I'm all talked out I like if
I want to share something I will fight
you for the microphone okay but go ahead
I remember when you were pregnant the
first time you were saying hey you
literally just like can't order in food
anymore like you had to cook for a
multitude of reasons but honestly I've
been really feeling that way like I
can't I always order in first of all
it's so financially irresponsible and
two it's never even good no it's slap
and you end up paying literally double
with like the fee and everything so I've
like had a lot of groceries I've been
trying to like make meals and last night
I was like you know what I'm gonna make
myself some food
and the way I have literally never not
once in my life successfully made
something I have made things that ended
up fine and edible but it wasn't correct
like turkey is low-key a horrible Chef
like every time you go on one of those
shows world's worst Cooks every time you
set out to make something it comes out
totally wrong like I remember when you
made panel vodka and like you got drunk
we were all getting wasted we got wasted
on the pasta remember the one
Thanksgiving where I was like okay I
will make the mashed potatoes and it was
actual concrete yeah
I have never successfully made anything
and even when I've made something that's
edible it's still not correct it's just
like decent yes so last night I was so
excited I was like playing music I was
chopping I was gonna make taco meat and
rice like I just I love taco meat I
don't even need like the whole Taco
station like I just need meat and so I'm
I'm cooking I got garlic olive oil and
onions on the pan I'm Browning my meat
and the one thing in my house that I
always have like I don't really I'm an
ingredients house like I don't have a
lot of stuff oh my the truckers are out
here truckers for tacos
um
I always have those Pockets packets of
Old El Paso seasoning like I love Old El
Paso I am their number one customer I
think what they're doing is great and I
didn't even check before I started I'm
like I know I have it cute to the time
to add the [__] seasoning and I don't
have any
I'm like [__] and Ben has told me that
like Old El Paso he's like it's not
authentic like you can make it real I'm
like all right so we always have because
we also make a lot of chili we always
have the makings of taco seasonings like
the seasonings that go into the packet
yes so I just Googled it delish.com
crapola.com I followed the thing to a
team to a tea to a T I had my little uh
you know teaspoon thing okay
I made it in a bowl I'm mixing it I'm
like you know it smells a little funky
in the bowl but I'm like you know it
just it needs to get in there before it
really starts to smell like the old El
Paso oh my God not only did it smell
[__] horrible once I like added
everything into the pan
but it also had this like chunky
consistency like it was like not melding
with the meat it was like dry do you
know that you need to add water I did
okay I just learned this I just learned
that last week because I never made
tacos before I didn't know that but it
was like simple math I'm like this looks
dry let me add water you know oh look at
you charity not me I'm like if they
didn't tell me to do it I can't do it so
I get everything in there I let it
simmer my house smells like a [__]
crematorium it smelled so disgusting I
couldn't and then I felt pregnant too
because I was like I'm telling you I'm
having sympathy I'm like I'm not even
gonna try this it's so smelly and
disgusting like I'll make myself sick
you're having munchausen's pregnancy 100
so I literally threw away the whole
thing such a [__] waste of meat of
time my back was killing me I'm
literally pregnant after standing in the
kitchen it took me 90 minutes to do this
whole thing like my back was hurting I
was wearing a bra that was a huge
mistake uh I was so hungry and I just
ended up eating egg noodles
so did it smell bad for turdy or like
for everyone would have thought it
smelled bad it just wasn't like was it
you because you're very particular
everyone and I know what tacos smell
like and that wasn't tacos where do you
think you went wrong I couldn't tell you
if I tried honestly fucktalish.com
that's where I went wrong let me see
what their taco seasoning recipe is it
sounded right like cumin onion powders
garlic powder uh chili powder paprika
salt pepper I had everything except for
maybe the paprika and they said like
that was like if you like a spicy and I
don't even like yeah and all these
paprika's always like the teeniest bit
just for color right okay I did it right
homemade taco seasoning looks good in
the bowl it always looks good in their
fragile chili powder human done done I
know you don't love cumin but what like
it's not a lot one tablespoon oh
actually yeah it actually kind of like
overpowered for sure the cumin yeah
smoke pack brica I didn't have okay
that's fine garlic powder onion powder
good
fresh ground pepper and dried oregano
what's bad
maybe it was the cumin you didn't like
it's very potent can can seasonings go
bad because like my seasoning cabinet
like that is also so turdy yes
every seasoning that's in my house was
purchased is the first one that's ever
been in my house like I don't replenish
I never finished seasoning does anyone
it only has 3.9 stars on the reviews out
of five so maybe you're like well just
wait till I get in there and I give it
zero Stars
do you use too much or too little
I did the [__] measuring
yeah
the people in the comments aren't like
thrilled with the recipe but it sounds
like non-nefarious but the thing about
turdy and it's like just something sweet
about turkey is that she can't cook I
know try she may you like you obviously
like you know what you're doing you
chopped onions and you were like
sizzling in the kitchen but you always
always [__] it up
every single you just I don't have that
je ne sais quoi I don't have the you
know the green thumb for cooking no
you really don't and maybe it's because
you like can't follow directions you
don't like to follow like you're a real
breaker not a real follower no and I'm
really impatient yeah yeah especially
about food again you'll cut Any Corner
that you see 100 like when I make pasta
like I refuse to wait for the water to
boil like oh it's a little hot throw it
in that's so funny I'm like if it's not
rip roilin we're not going in no I don't
give a rip it's going in you don't give
a rip I'm waiting for it to rip I can't
like I really can't and that's why I
just order in and that's why I had like
a ship meal last night and I was just
like feeling [__] and that's why you
have Ben also
I know it's like I actually really miss
Ben like mostly because I'm hungry but
you don't even like what he makes
no I do I like what he makes for me when
he makes his own like [__] disgusting
ass like Dill infused tuna like I could
vomit it's it's so crazy it was really
[__] annoying like oh what a
difficult night for me I'm so sorry you
had to go through that turdy uh Olivia
sent another dinner for us I know and
then I I had facetimed Olivia when I
couldn't find the Old El Paso seasoning
and that [__] didn't pick up so I
really do blame what happened next on
her because she didn't pick up and then
once it was destroyed she called me back
and she was like in the kitchen with the
kids cooking like this delicious meal
and like I actually in that moment I
never felt so low I was like I should be
there I don't have a meal I don't have
that [__] and be me
I don't have anyone in my house to enjoy
this meal with like I felt lonely I felt
sad I felt hungry it was really hard and
like everyone her her kitchen was
popping with life and love and mine was
just filled with Dread
you were a low down turd I couldn't
honestly I had to hang up I understand
and call me
who was also cooking no it was
disgusting
I'm sorry charity that you went through
that we're all here for you it's okay
drop your favorite Taco homemade taco
seasoning recipe in the comments because
I actually I have a jar of taco
seasoning
um I think I might have Old El Pasto but
I never used it but I just got like you
know one of the seasoning jars whatever
and I've made it twice now and I can
tell like it's not my favorite version
of taco seasoning so like I would love
to try someone else's let me know
somebody one I spoke a little bit about
what I did last night on my Instagram
and people were sending their tips and
somebody sent the most absolutely
[__] unhinged tip I've ever
seen in my life ready chair they were
like once the meat is brown like don't
add taco seasoning put it in a big bowl
with an entire jar of salsa
and you have taco meat
that's not what turdy's gonna like
obviously that person doesn't know turd
yeah right right I just want to shout
out Old El Paso I love them I don't know
if it's considered like white people
Taco I hope it's like a really authentic
I hope it's like a Mexican owned and
operated brand because like I love to
support yeah I think their shells their
tortillas their seasoning I think
everything they make is amazing it seems
so authentic to me and I don't even want
to look into the company background
because if it's not authentic Mexican
like I'll feel bad no I feel like it
probably is I know I feel like it's
owned by Goya that's just like like some
maybe they were like
yeah that's in the El Paso company and
Goya is Mexican owned
so whenever I make chili I go Goya what
okay chili Mexican
what company owns El Paso okay General
Mills owns it now but hopefully they
bought it from yeah
oh that's so not authentic
uh
what about like about us
yeah like who started Old El Paso
let me ask that next who started
Old El Paso maybe with a name like that
they've got to be authentic
the mountain pass canning company
launched the Old El Paso brand [__] okay
Mountain Pass canning company
let's check them out it sounds like it
was started by a major corporation to
trick Americans into thinking they're
having authentic Mexican culinary
experiences in 1917 the mountain pass
canning company in New Mexico was bought
from a local in El Paso Texas
so
who started the mountain pass who's the
local in Old El Paso yeah Mountain Pass
canning company this is giving me
Marjorie post if you know you know
honestly 1900s
I feel like I feel like it's authentic
they're making it so difficult for you
to find out yep and also now I'm back to
the old El Paso site where it said it
all started in 1917 when the mountain
pass canning company was established by
AC Powell in New Mexico
American camper
so you're saying American power was a
farmer and grew his successful
Enterprise from an original Seven Acre
Farm with as much help as he could
muster from his family and neighbors
that's a sweet story of community is he
Mexican
Powell
he's not a Mexican
the company was one of the first to can
tomatoes but it also produced pinto
beans corn Chile and Alfalfa all grown
on the expanding Farm then in 1938 the
mountain pass canning company launched
the Old El Paso brand which was soon
known for its fiery taco sauce from our
humble beginning making canned beans and
taco sauce we've always been there to
offer you the best Mexican recipes that
the whole family will love
so it sounds like maybe they are
whitewashing taco
and Mexican culinary Cuisine yes
it's still so good but you know what it
still tastes the same no so you know
what let me tell you I will continue to
use their products but I won't feel good
doing it and that's the price I pay
yeah where or you could you know drop
your favorite uh Mexican owned Mexican
food brand drop it yeah but I like the
little packets like that's what makes it
easy like I'm so simple-minded in the
kitchen yeah it can't be getting
complicated complicated the packages are
nice a packet
well I'm sure after this they'll send
you a lifetime supply this one that
would happen to again turdy
and it shouldn't yeah
you know all this Taco talk has actually
made me quite thirsty so why don't you
tell everyone a little story and I'm
gonna go get a sparkling water oh okay
I'll tell you a story about the oh she's
taking her headphones off I was gonna
like butter her up
um
you know what I have a great story
because yesterday I was editing our
episode of the redheads which drops
tomorrow oh I've gotta finish episode
editing it and the way I tell you it was
such an enjoyable podcast
I picked my head up and I was 40 minutes
into the episode I literally swear I had
just started editing it and I was like
damn they don't make podcasts like this
like more people need to know about the
redheads and so tomorrow it drops and
you don't want to miss it because it's
honestly premium stuff and you don't
have to have read the book because we
always summarize it in the beginning of
the episode I was just saying I was
adding the redheads episode yesterday I
heard the whole thing I heard the whole
thing oh I was oh because if you were
listening the whole time I was going to
tell them about the Best Day Of My Life
July 10th 1994. that's so sweet I just
wanted to clarify for everyone listening
as a podcast
um I got a Diet Coke not a sparkling
water oh thank you for holding yourself
accountable it's so important to be
authentic when you have a brand like
this yes and people are literally
watching you on the camera
yeah I know and I know someone was going
to call me out so
I just got to call myself out first that
was a nice sip of water
should we dive in I'm so excited to read
this year toaster Studio like oh okay
greatly wait yeah I'm ready without
further Ado About Claudia's Taco
disaster Taco Time
and you bringing new life into this
world like let's not make this episode
about me yeah no but that where we were
like a doing about that you know if
anything yeah we talked about the tacos
longer than the new life no we
definitely talked about it like a little
too much
I don't think so it's such an important
topic though it really is so without
further Ado here are the past five
stories that you do need to know
and the best five stories that you do
need to know is are brought to you by
canopy
so if you haven't been using a
humidifier or you're into humidifiers
that you want to get into humidifiers
whether it's for your skin your overall
sleep your overall Wellness you should
really check out canopy because
traditional humidifiers are notorious
for being ugly getting moldy and
impossible to maintain but that's where
the canopy humidifier comes in it's
recommended by Leading dermatologists
the canopy humidifier is a completely
reimagined humidifier that elevates your
home for the ultimate in skin care and
wellness benefits so it is winter out
here our skin is getting crusty and dry
especially in our sleep I wake up with
dry skin but I also wake up with really
dry like nasal passages and like a dry
throat that almost feels like I'm like
sick but I'm not and when I sleep with a
humidifier I can't tell you how much of
a difference there is in how I wake up
and I feel like yesterday we were having
this long conversation about like always
feeling like crap when you wake up and
getting a humidifier is an amazing place
to start their unique features and
design make it the easiest cleanest
humidifier out there it is truly healthy
Skin's best kept secret it has a clean
no mist moisture sure that effortlessly
hydrates your skin to combat dryness
dullness and fine lines and wrinkles
it's hassle-free technology inhibits
mold growth and on the parts go right
into the dishwasher it's that easy so go
to getcanopy.co to save 25 on your
canopy humidifier purchase today with
canopy's Filter subscription even better
use code toast at checkout and save an
additional 10 off your canopy purchase
your skin will thank you so we've got
two codes for you guys when you go to
cat you go to getcanopy.com save that 25
dollars
then use code toast to get an additional
10 off your canopy purchase get
canopy.co
thank you Claudia yeah well Alex who's
Claudia I don't know I just feel like my
turd count is already at like 50 for the
episode so I just wanted to switch it up
oh my God if this was like watch Happens
live like our drinking game of the night
would every day be turning yeah and you
would be drunk every night
aren't we all
no we're not no no
um our first
sorry that's what it is it is a story
and it is some music news Ed Sheeran
announces his new Honest album not
called honest the album just is an album
in which there is honesty and reveals
that his wife Cherry Seaborn had a tumor
during pregnancy oh my God so he is back
with the latest installment of his
mathematical albums this one is called
minus subtract subtract and it's called
subtract I didn't now that I realized it
I know the divided one the division what
was that multiply
I never realized that I thought he had x
divided no
they're all meth and I believe this is
the fourth one yeah and then he's going
on tour that's like x divided you know
minus plus and it's called the
mathematics tour
it honestly should be called the PEMDAS
tour
it's a lot and it's funny this article
says with you know minus symbol
pronounce subtract that's the name of
the album he'll cover a difficult period
that spurred him to musically reflect on
his deepest darkest thoughts he
announced Wednesday in a press release
he put out a really long statement very
honest um saying I had been working on
subtract for a decade trying to sculpt
the perfect acoustic album writing and
recording hundreds of songs with a Clear
Vision of what I thought it should be
then at the start of 2022 a series of
events changed my life my meant my mute
my mental health and ultimately the way
I viewed music and art
writing songs is my therapy it helps me
make sense of my feelings I wrote
without thought of what the songs would
be I just wrote Whatever tumbled out and
in just over a week I replaced a decades
worth of work with my deepest darkest
thoughts within the space of a month my
pregnant wife got told she had a tumor
with no root to treatment until after
the birth
um they did Welcome a second daughter in
May of last year
but he said my best friend Jamal a
brother to me died suddenly and I found
myself standing in court defending my
integrity and career as a songwriter I
was spiraling through fear depression
and anxiety that's referencing when he
was
um sued for shape of you it sounds like
something else he said I felt like I was
drowning head below the surface looking
up and not being able to break through
for air he added that this inspired him
to put out an album that accurately
represented what he was experiencing
quote it's opening the trap door into my
soul for the first time I'm not trying
to craft an album people will like I'm
merely putting something out that's
honest and true to where I am in my
adult life this is last February's diary
entry and my way of making sense of it
this is subtract
so I really like this explanation and it
also makes me really excited for the
album because I feel like his divide
album which had Castle on the hill
um Galway Girl Supermarket flowers like
was so good like so honest and like so
it had Ops it had anthems it had
acoustic like it was really one of the
best albums ever and then I really felt
like Ed Sheeran like went to this like
weird like pop star place where he was
just like making crap over the last
couple of years like bad habits that new
song I hate that's all and it's just not
who we've come to know as Ed Sheeran you
know he's really like this strip Back
guitar guy and I really feel like this
album is going to be really good yeah
I've never immersed myself in Ed Sheeran
you know I'm kind of like forced to
listen to his music because he's always
on the radio I find Ed Sheeran songs
that I do like aren't even the ones that
of course most radio play like Castle on
the hill came out at the exact same time
as that other crappy song what song and
like I think shape of you is a horrible
song yet it was like Grammy like it
couldn't it couldn't have been a bigger
song make it make sense uh I Castle on
the hill after reading this explanation
I'm so excited for this album I feel
like it's gonna be a complete work it's
not just about like singles and Bops and
radio plays like it's a it's telling a
story and I feel like it's I mean he
every album he puts out is great
but I I feel like this will hit
different it intends for it to hit
different it's I'm sure there will still
be hits from it because he's a hit maker
but I'm really excited to hear what he
has to say me too I completely agree I
feel like his explanation of it is
making me really excited about it and it
feels like it's going to be like
what he's known for which are like it's
not these like pop Anthem like you know
dance in the club
songs it's like these really Honest
acoustic songs yes that's like how when
you think about it when you yeah right
when you think about the song that
really launched him is the A Team it's
like this really stripped Down song and
like that's what we've come to expect
from him but then in recent years he
took this weird turn
yeah I think he got maybe caught up in
the industry he probably got a million
opportunities to like do big things but
now he's back to his roots and I think
he took off a lot of time and and I did
feel like we missed him and we would be
like throughout the years like where's
that cheer and what's Ed Sheeran doing
and so this feels really genuine not
just like I'm taking a break from social
media two months back here's a song
about what the last two months what I
learned yeah
um I it also got me thinking because
I've always wondered you know he will
run out of sides you know he has plus he
has X he has divide he is equal now he
has subtract so he's kind of gone
through all of the elementary
mathematical signs but I thought of one
last night that I feel like he could use
what
oh
like the slash like a factor you know
three-fourths like and it can be called
Factor
okay interesting the these four five I
didn't realize he has equal two like
yeah that makes sense as well because
it's usually the four like of course
plus minus divide at uh multiply
so then he had it equal which is smart I
feel like it's time to do something
different after this you think
yeah without it getting silly honestly
I'm and I'm so embarrassed to say I
didn't even notice he was doing this I
noticed it like a few years ago but I
didn't immediately notice it either and
I was always like what the [__] is this
album called X yeah
I literally never thought about it yeah
it's it's like a quirky thing about Ed
it's cute I feel like other artists do
that too this is actually a really well
done version of it
I don't know what's next totally random
you know it's like a pet peeve of mine
because I feel like um Miley Cyrus just
announced her tracklist
and all the songs are in all caps
and then some people do it like all
lowercase yeah Ari
uh Taylor's been doing that it really
[__] bothers me yeah
I I like a capitalization I also don't
like all caps though because I'm not me
either I'm not that passionate about
anything it's a title so you just do
like the first letter of the word like I
hate when people try to get creative
with like caps and stuff like just stick
to the you know English language yeah
the all lower case I associated with
Ariana now so it doesn't bother me when
she does it but it just seems like
unnecessary
I it really bothers my yeah I feel like
people used to do that like on their
phones and computers like you can turn
off auto capitalization so their texts
always start with a lower case it's just
so informal yeah no I think like people
used to do that back in the day because
like they were so chill you know like
not like other girls like I'm so relaxed
like this text is just like answer it
sure whatever like I don't care you know
who weirdly has that not for their texts
but still uh she did it so long ago that
all the contacts in her phone start with
a lowercase no Olivia ashrae
oh see there's decisions you make when
you're young can really haunt you into
your adulthood that was like her
aesthetic to talk to her about it maybe
we'll see maybe we'll find out that
there's a reason behind that like if she
ever sends you someone's contact you'll
notice it's a lowercase oh that's
interesting text her now and be like can
you send me
um yeah someone's number like someone
who she like knows from like college or
something
can you send me I'm gonna say marnie's
number I was just thinking okay
so that's so funny
the iCloud is crazy not to put her on
blast but
I wonder if she still does it when I see
her I'll ask her yeah and when I respond
when she responds I'll let you know
um okay well excited for this album
comes out May 5th
May the 5th so the day before snitch's
birthday so we'll all listen that day
and then the next day we'll celebrate
since she's birthday and the car nation
and Taylor Swift in Nashville I think
it's so crazy how you said May 5th the
day before since his birthday like not
only is it the anniversary of our
deceased father's birthday but it's also
the one year anniversary of me playing
Madison Square Garden so thanks and it's
Cinco de Mayo so you could have all the
Old El Paso tacos you want should I have
like an old El Paso themed cinco de mayo
party Old El Paso should throw you guys
should do like a collab brand event
where they throw you like a cinco de
mayo party for you and your influencer
friends to like eat tacos and take pics
and like drink tequila yeah love free
marketing idea
I just feel like and I don't know how or
why but like me doing that would be like
extremely offensive to Mexican culture
oh yeah and I actually I can understand
why like I'm not Mexican neither is Old
El Paso but we're like we're out here
like LARPing as Mexicans no I don't
think you have to like LARP as a Mexican
in order to
enjoy the festivities okay that would be
like Lauren Elizabeth love her she's not
Jewish and manishevitz throwing a
Hanukkah party like
yeah it's weird
yeah
it's a it's a little different but um I
understand sorry like are you not meant
to celebrate Cinco de Mayo at all
because Lord Smith is not meant to
celebrate Hanukkah right I think you
can't you know what I don't know I'll
have to ask someone who's Mexican
because I can't speak for them like are
we encouraged to celebrate everyone I
think they are but I think there's a
respectful way of doing it of course of
course no I understand I could see how
you know that wearing sombreros and fake
mustaches like that's not appropriate
that's not the way to do it but I could
also see if you know you became the face
of like Old El pasos
that wouldn't play well no it'd be
problematic for sure yeah no you're
right about that so yeah maybe I take
the idea back
oh wait Olivia sent me
uh three videos of Michaela how blessed
am I did she see your original text I
don't know emphasize it send it um send
the exclamations I am okay
well I'll have to watch those videos
Michaela later have fun she's sleeping
in the car she's wearing a tutu oh my
God I'm obsessed
oh are you ready for our next story yeah
Travis Scott is accused of punching a
man in the face and causing twelve
thousand dollars worth of equipment
damage this week wait hold on like you
just said Travis Scott
and like my mind took 45 minutes to
place who that is because one we haven't
spoken about him in so long and the
Travis we have been talking about is
Kelsey oh wow so I was like wait who the
[__] is Travis Scott no Travis like so
many people that are named Travis Travis
Barker yeah Travis Kelsey Travis Scott
but you don't even like know their name
Travis until you really think about it
and then you said about the name Travis
too long and it sounds like garage like
you can't say too many times because it
stops sounding like a word Travis
I wonder what the war what the name
Travis means and what's its origin
Travis name Travis comes from the Greek
word
travilakis which means man it's derived
from the old French World
old French word traverser meaning to
cross ah we're traversing we're
traversing through Travis's interesting
um but this Travis of the Scott variety
allegedly punched a man in the face and
cost twelve thousand dollars worth of
damage to equipment police sources tell
page six they're told cops responded to
an assault call early Wednesday at
nebula in Midtown where the sicko mode
rapper allegedly got into a verbal turn
physical altercation with a sound
engineer the alleged victim did not
complain of pain or have any visible
injuries at the time of the report
Travis also allegedly damaged a video
screen and speaker before departing the
nightclub in an unknown vehicle
page six has learned that only a
complaint was made and that Scott has
not been arrested in connection to the
alleged uh incident
um
Travis Scott is on a one-way trip to
nowhere I don't know what the [__] he's
doing every time I hear about him it's
like something worse well not worse but
it's just more bad [__] and honestly he
needs to reevaluate his life honestly
yeah and I'm sure like he's also
spiraling now that Kylie is done with
him for now right they're very on and
off but you know when you don't have a
woman to like tether you yeah you can
you can be untethered you spin out
you're rootless and there's nothing
worse than being untethered a hundred
percent and it causes you to just like
act erratically like this yeah
so
not good not good do better actually in
an actual way I'm not saying it in an
ironic way I'm saying like do better
like you have a family like you're a
role model to people like do better yeah
do better things
make better choices maybe surround
yourself with better people maybe like
who you're surrounding yourself with is
not me influencing you to make good
choices
do better
are you ready for our next story some
Royal drama
yeah King Charles has evicted Harry and
Megan from Frogmore Cottage and he did
it 24 after 24 hours after spare was
published and guess who's moving in
I don't know prince Andrew
I know but it's a major downgrade for
prince Andrew he was living on 98 Acres
uh with a 30 room estate paying like 250
pounds a month in government subsidized
housing right and now he's moving to
Frogmore cottage which we saw bits and
pieces of in the documentary it's not
you know a palace it's not what you
would imagine Royals living in yeah so I
think he was under pressure to like put
prince Andrew in smaller accommodations
and also he's done like Harry and him
are done so yeah and but Harry and Megan
were never gonna stay there anyway like
I don't think they stayed there for the
carnation
the Carnation the Jubilee
oh did they yeah because in the
documentary they had like pictures from
Jubilee weekend where they went back
they were at the Jubilee they went and
they left early
okay
yeah okay all right so overall this is a
fairly inconsequential because like they
don't live in [__] UK
yeah no but like if they were ever going
back if if who knows if they'll even be
at the car Nation this makes me think no
but remember we just reported that
Charles wants his legacy to be reuniting
his family right but if they have to
stay you know down the street at a hotel
I don't think there's much honestly
reunification and to be used served by
prince Andrew yes I mean slap in the
face the way they spoke about Frogmore
in the documentary like they obviously
thought of it as a dump so they should
be happy that they're staying in a hotel
now because they'll stay at the Four
Seasons yes no they were in a place
before Frogmore that was dumpy the one
that Oprah went to and was like people
wouldn't believe that you lived like
this right and then they got upgraded to
Frogmore when they got engaged or
married
um and that's where she was pregnant and
it was much homier though still not a
palace on a hill it is it's like a
cottage it is Frogmore Cottage so King
Charles Cavalier Spaniel III Bryson
strassen began the process of evicting
Harry and Megan from Frogmore Cottage
accidentally clicked a different link
uh just 24 hours after his son released
spare it was claimed today his majesty
initially gave his son and
daughter-in-law weeks to pack up their
grace and favor British home in the
grounds of Windsor Castle after his son
released his Memoirs but now they have
at least until after the Carnation in
May a friend of the couple has claimed A
source told page six at um King Charles
began the eviction process on January
11th the day after spare had its Global
release
the sussexes have reportedly planning
reportedly started planning how to move
their belongings to California including
an ornate ottoman bench and a Shay's
Lounge from the home they lived in until
mexit and stayed at following the
Queen's death last September oh and I
guess when they went back for right for
the funeral for the funeral
you know what Queenie was everything but
she definitely had a blind spot for her
children and I think a lot of people
were like disappointed there wasn't more
of like a brouhaha for prince Andrew you
know to answer for his crimes obviously
there was no legal repercussions but
even like he got stripped of his uniform
whatever titles but like he still lived
like you said 200 Acres Prince Vibes 98
Acres 30 of your Mansion called Windsor
Royal Lodge so you know what I kind of
love this power move for Charles like he
obviously doesn't have the same
affection and blind spot for his brother
that his mother did so you know what
here for it yeah two birds one stone for
him and Eugenie both the girls are
married right so they're both living out
of the house it's not affecting them
because they're innocent in this yeah
they still live in the cottage I'm sure
there Charles's nieces and and they seem
lovely I'm sure they could stay wherever
they want when they come back everyone
goes to Kensington that seems to be yeah
a hub of Royal activity I would want to
stay in Buckingham Palace guests
obviously but I think that they wouldn't
because like there's Taurus in there all
day I know that's like the weird thing
about Buckingham Palace it's so big so
like you don't ever like see a tourist
on your way to go brush your teeth but
like she's literally living in the same
place like all these snot-nosed you know
Globetrotters come and like walk through
the halls of it's really crazy it is but
that's like so
part of the royal fabric it's like
you're a part of British tourism yeah no
you live in a palace but you're also
kind of like an animal a civil servant
yeah
so very interesting Royal moves being
made
we shall see what happens I wonder if
prince Andrew will be at the car Nation
I feel like no I feel like Charles is
like really
consumed with his public perception yeah
um and he wants to come out a hero and
that
kind of excluding prince Andrew and and
not really reminding everyone of him is
a good place to start
I think he'll be there in a disgraced
position like how at the funeral he you
know walked in the back with Harry and
they were both not wearing it Garb right
um if he wanted to kick him out of the
royal folk completely he wouldn't be
living in Frogmore true true so I think
getting scraps yeah it's I don't think
he'll have like a position of prominence
but I think also a part of Charles once
like following his mom's footsteps and
the way that she treated Andrew seemed
to be good enough for everyone yeah so
it's just like
problem no but it's like the treatment
of a mother and a son is so different
than the treatment of a brother and a
brother like obviously there's a
brotherly connection yeah and I think
they were ever that close I think
survive I've gotten is like Andrew was
her favorite too favorite yeah even when
he came in in the crown like on his
helicopter and he was just like what's
up y'all yeah yeah yeah yeah he's such a
problem honestly like
he's a big problem nobody knows what to
do with him it would have been easier if
he literally just got convicted one to
answer for his crimes it too so he'd be
in jail and nobody had to have somewhere
to live where do we seat him where do we
put him to live like he's this like
never-ending like problem and you can't
even like put him out to live on the
street because he can't have a job and
he doesn't I mean he might have personal
money but still you'd have to like pay
for where he lives and then it's like
the government's paying for Andrew's
right right every there's no winning
with Andrew no he's so problematic yeah
so it's the solution for now
are you ready for our next story a
little Tech news a tech news Tick Tock
will automatically limit teen app usage
to 60 minutes per day
Tick Tock in an effort to show it's
being a good internet citizen introduce
new features to cap the time kids spend
on the video app in the next few weeks
every tick tock account belonging to a
user under the age of 18 will
automatically be set to a 60-minute
daily screen time limit if the limit is
reached teens will be prompted to enter
a passcode in order to continue watching
requiring them to make an active
decision to extend that time oh wait so
they could just get around it yeah
unless like someone sets the code for
them like a parent and they don't know
the code but or
when you sign up for your account you
just lie about your age it's not that
hard yeah also Tick Tock for tick tock
users under 13 which is so scary like I
know what are they doing on Tick Tock
the daily screen time limit will also be
set for 60 minutes and for these
accounts a parent or Guardian must enter
the passcode to enable 30 minutes of
additional watch time this is
performative there are so many ways
around this I think they've gotten so
much Flack over the years like all the
platforms are really toxic but there's
something especially addictive addicting
and just flawed with Tick Tock when it
comes to like people especially girls
whose brains aren't fully developed and
they're still very impressionable
um and so this is just their response to
the backlash it's not a meaningful step
forward and there's so many kids are so
when I think about how much [__] we used
to download illegally like when you when
it comes to kids in technology like
they're [__]
on it they can figure [__] out and this
is not gonna by any means decrease their
screen time no
it's giving fraudulent energy
it is what more can Tick Tock do
as an app that's also trying to make
money like what would you want to see
from Tick Tock is it tick tock's
responsibility is it parents
responsibility is it government
responsibility that's a good question I
think it's everyone's I think probably
probably most and maybe you have a
better answer the parents because
there's always [__] in this world that's
bad yeah and it's your parents job to
protect you from it
um but kids are so sneaky you know like
those yeah and like really whatever they
want can you tell a 17 year old
like a 17 year old's gonna have a phone
because they they do need a phone at 17.
yeah how can you please what they do on
there I don't know how logistically you
can do that I'm really thinking and more
concerned with kids who are like under
14. yeah well those kids are more in in
like a parent's
don't yeah you know jurisdiction yeah
like they have to their parents more I
feel like there should definitely be
like an age like how you couldn't get on
Facebook back in the day until you were
in high school or college first college
then High School I think it would be who
a lot of the platforms to have age
limits that they that they really
enforce like with Facebook back in the
day you could not make a Facebook unless
you had a college email yeah you
verified it was [__] hard yeah so and
I actually think that's something I'm so
grateful for like I really didn't they
didn't change the high school thing
until I was in high school so like I was
at least 16.
I know that's not true but no no you I
had a Facebook in middle school no but
you could get on as a freshman it didn't
happen while you were in high school I
remember being in middle school waiting
to get to high school and then I could
have a Facebook like the minute I got my
high school email address I'm on
Facebook yeah
yeah so I just think I think that was
really helpful and I don't even think
they intended it to be but it was and
having age limits on a lot of these
platforms I think would be extremely
that they actually enforced not just
like you have to be 13 and then I can go
make my my birthday 1994 you know right
I think there's ways to to action if you
actually cared there would be ways and
policies and things but this is
fraudulent it's performative yeah there
would need to be sweeping stuff also
like when you get a phone if there would
be a way to really put in your like the
phone knows what age you are you can't
download certain apps at that age like I
think if everybody came together because
this is a crisis our children are in
crisis 100 and it's on all of us to help
them because they're always going to go
for you know Candy over veggies the
thing that they can't get you're so
right and I feel like all we do is talk
about the Mental Health crisis in this
country and like all we do is just talk
about how it's here I mean talk talk we
just talk talk talk talk talk talk and
it's become like a a form of social
currency like oh I'm mental health
problem oh so do I no and we talk about
anything and we talk about how social
media is bad and where do we talk about
it on social media right so it's like
nobody actively does anything about it
so it's like people don't actually care
about the Mental Health crisis in this
country they just want to talk about it
they just don't want to actually do
anything and this is an incredibly
effective place to start if your phone
knew how old you were and in the App
Store you were forbidden from
downloading certain apps until you were
like 16. yeah each app could like figure
out amongst themselves watch what would
happen to the Mental Health crisis and
the suicide rates in this country and
the depression and the anxiety for girls
who are 12 years old yeah
so if you actually maybe if you actually
[__] cared you would do something
about it because we're sitting here for
five minutes and we're two brain dead
[__] morons and we came up with good
ideas or if there was like an app for
kids that was like Instagram and Tick
Tock but you could only follow people
whose phone number you have so you're
only following your friends and it
really becomes like a social network and
not following you know a 12 year old
girl following like some
beautiful
Buxom 22 year old and then trying to
like be like her makeup just like her
yeah but it's not even that it's also
like that girl you know it's it winds up
being a bad influence because you know
body image Etc but then there are also
people who are intentionally putting out
nefarious content and trying to [__]
with kids yeah of course so I like my
quality we should build it we should
start like a coalition yeah
and you can only follow people's phone
numbers you have there's no following
influencers and now everyone wants to be
an influencer because they follow them
all day long like right well yeah solved
problem solved put us no
like
that's what I'm saying we've been
talking about this for five minutes and
we came up with like actually good
effective ideas Tick Tock this billion
dollar company filled with like you know
genius Tech Engineers this is the best
they came up with this is both because
they don't care right they don't care no
and Tick Tock is not concerned with the
American children's well-being no no no
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is kind of like the collab
of the century food news we haven't had
food news in a while okay and it's two
brands that we love
coming together Harmony not acrimony is
it Spritz Society extra skinny
confidential available at sports
society.com our new pink lemonade flavor
which is a limited edition collab with
Lauren Bostic founder of the skinny
confidential and host of the his and
hers podcast
what that what spritzex TSC is to the
influencer and beverage Community yeah
it is this to the fast food Community
McDonald's and Krispy Kreme are teaming
up McDonald's is expanding their Krispy
Kreme test to more Kentucky locations
so McDonald's will sell Krispy Kreme
donuts at approximately 160 Kentucky
locations starting next month for a
limited time it's an expansion of the
fast food Giants initial test with the
Sweet Treats in October nine McDonald's
restaurants in Louisville started
selling Krispy Kreme Donuts the large
test is meant to assess customer demand
and to understand how a larger scale
launch would affect restaurant
operations so they're not making like a
a collab item they're just starting to
sell Donuts yes
let me tell you my thoughts on this I
think it's great because I think when it
comes to dessert McDonald's definitely
kind of flops because their ice cream
machines are always broken I've never I
mean I don't I've never
I probably get McFlurries like three
times a year and it's always been a
success
no they're always broken of course the
McFlurry is a perfect concoction it is
the greatest dessert literally in the
world honestly maybe second only to a
Krispy Kreme donut so I love this I do
worry about quality control you know
Krispy Kreme donuts are perfect when
they come from Krispy Kreme when they
they sell actually at my local Dwayne
Reed they sell they have a little uh
stand of Krispy Kreme products and they
have like boxes of glazed donuts and
they're not even close to being as good
so as long as they can work on how to
keep them fresh and maybe serve them hot
I I worry about that because I think
overall McDonald's definitely has a
quality control issue like you can get a
nugget at one place and nugget out of
the other and they literally taste
completely different I wouldn't know
yeah except the few times that I ordered
fries from my local McDonald's in New
York it was the ones I fell on the floor
and were stomped on right like they have
they're not really all the same no
um in fact I would start to order from a
further McDonald's of course if done
correctly but then they're not hot you
seriously can't win that's why you make
your own fries and grow your own
potatoes if done correctly
this could be great yeah because they
are beefing up their coffee you know
they have the mick Cafe but what I also
love is they're not trying to make a
better donut because someone at
McDonald's knows that a better donut
doesn't exist it's actually so true why
don't we team up there is no I in team
there's no eye in Krispy Kreme and make
this a One-Stop shop especially because
for how many McDonald's there are in the
country there's a fraction of the Krispy
Kreme so like
imagine if every McDonald's in New York
City obviously this isn't happening had
Krispy Kreme all of a sudden there's
dozens of Krispy Kremes in New York City
no and by the way then McDonald's really
becomes like an early morning competitor
to like a Dunkin Donuts because you want
a good coffee and McDonald's coffee
actually is very popular and it's very
good
um so then it's like oh let me get a
coffee and a Donut coffee and an egg
sandwich people really like their
breakfast
it's kind of becoming like a cafe like a
bistro you know Mint Cafe right I like
this I like this too
I
do love Dunkin Donuts
I like it
no because uh I like it no I do like
that you know what I like their egg
wraps
so that's munchkin I don't love their
coffee their quality control is [__]
frightening on coffee it's actually
abysmal on everything a munchkin to to
tasty tasty I also absolutely love
whenever we have a fast food story
because we obviously then just go into
like talking about all the different
branches of things and we always get PR
we end up getting an email like I loved
your segment on Krispy Kreme can we send
some product to the studio
um and that's just always it happens
like a lot and it's very exciting what
are you hoping for today some Krispy
Kreme donuts
I mean I will just I will literally
never turn never in my life I could be
on literally death's door I will never
turn down a Christmas that's when I
would accept one most immediately no
like I'm so sick I'm on that storm I'm
so sick I can't put anything in my body
and then like somebody cruises by with a
donut I'm like hey give me that yeah
yeah yeah
so good especially when they're fresh
from the oven yeah but you could also
just warm them up you know it's 15
seconds in the microwave really really
good obviously not hot off the presses
but
Stellar actually I just had one like a
few weeks ago because Danny brought some
over when she came to visit us which was
just so sweet and generous the last time
I had one actually was
um December when did I film my special
December
um because there was like a crew of like
40 people and I wanted to get them like
a snack so I got them all done it's like
for me but also for them and I got like
eight boxes for everyone and I had like
six it was so good you definitely didn't
have six
no I had like two you definitely didn't
because I know you now and you're so
slim no I had to you had two Krispy
Dreams yeah wow throughout the day oh
throughout the day okay okay throughout
the day one when the boxes got there
because I wanted them fresh and then two
like after the show like I worked hard
it's a long day sorry I thought you
meant like just like you chowed down two
at a time no I'm trying to be better
with that
[Laughter]
um are you ready to dive into Deer
toasters with an update that's gonna
literally bring a tear to even the most
cynical of eyes are we starting with the
update no it's going to be last because
I'm annoying uh clickbait turdy deer
toasters is brought to you by
Squarespace
Squarespace is the One Stop Shop for
everything you need from websites and
online stores to marketing tools and
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business so
whether you work in e-commerce you've
been wanting to start an e-commerce
business you've got a side hustle
Squarespace is the perfect place to
start because they have everything you
need for e-commerce they have ways to
connect your social media accounts they
have really good insights into your
traffic overview they offer content
ownership so you own all the content
that you put on the Squarespace platform
with their one-click data portability
you have social sharing analytics
blogging tools email campaigns
um pretty much everything their websites
can be optimized for mobile for desktop
if you don't know how to build a website
you obviously don't have a background in
computer science or software engineering
don't fret because Squarespace makes it
so easy I have personally built many
websites over the years using different
platforms and from experience I can tell
you that Squarespace is really easy they
have really professional looking
websites that can take not a long time
and not a lot of effort to set up so so
check out squarespace.com toast for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use offer code toast to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain again that's squarespace.com
toast for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use offer code toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain you will have a
really easy time getting set up with
Squarespace and again
squarespace.com toast thank you all
right let's dive into Deer toasters are
you are you ready I'm ready to dive in
hey Jackson Claude I'm a long time
listener here my fiance and I have been
together for six years and we're getting
married this Summer since I was a
teenager I have been so insecure about
the hump on my nose now that I'm grown
and I'm in a more financially stable
situation I've been thinking about
finally getting my nose done especially
before our wedding my fiance
unfortunately does not support this at
all he thinks plastic surgery is
superficial and says he will never be
able to look at me the same way again
part of my work requires me to spend
time on camera so it's something that
really bothers me I know there is some
recovery time from rhinoplasty and we
plan to start a family next year so it's
something I would like to take care of
before that I'd like to start this new
season of my life see feeling more
confident however it causes conflict
every time I try to bring it up any
advice on how to navigate this is
welcome
that's really tough
I mean it literally doesn't matter what
that man thinks I know it doesn't want
his support and in an ideal world he
would support you and of course you know
it's better to have a husband that's
like no you're beautiful don't get
plastic surgery and then one who's like
shoving you out the door in bed right
now right oh my God that's actually
paying the bill
um my only thing is like you've waited
so long to get it and you're getting
married this Summer kind of seems like
kind of quick to just like now you have
to find a doctor and have a consultation
and get the surgery and recover before
your wedding while also wedding planning
and I kind of
would
advise just having like a a little less
haste you know because now it feels like
we're in a rush when like oh your whole
life I totally disagree I know if you're
gonna get a new nose like do it before
your wedding but like well not only that
like I literally just experienced this
with a really good friend of mine she
was getting married she hated her notes
her whole life and she just she did it
before
um and she was wedding planning and it
was stressful all that and she was so
happy she was so happy on her wedding
day she looked beautiful she loves her
nose now after and she gets to live her
life as a married woman with the new
nose and it was literally if you ask her
like she will say it was the best
decision she ever made and maybe she
would have said how soon how far away
from her wedding did she do it
let me think you know what she had a
cast on her nose at her bachelorette
party
when was her bachelor party in relation
to her wedding my bachelor party was
four months before
let me think hold on
he's Claudia's not good with dates this
is really I know I'm trying to think do
you remember what month she got married
I could tell you because like because if
you tell me where it was I'll tell you
I don't wanna yeah I know oh she got
another job even though I don't think
she cares but like I'm not trying to be
that [__]
where is this place on the map hold on
oh here
so she got married August okay and and
The Bachelorette I can check also when
my pictures are
The Bachelorette was
hmm
I think it's important just give me a
second it is it is okay The Bachelorette
was May okay and she had a castle she
got it in May and she got married in
August so it is oh it's only three it's
March now okay but like you've gotta
like you literally have to call a doctor
today then
yeah like you either you need to make a
decision now so like because you don't
have that much time but I'm all here for
it like I feel like I'm so
I'm not a pusher but I'm So Into plastic
surgery about things that really bother
you like that's just my philosophy I
hate this thing like Embrace who you are
like what if I don't want to my body my
[__] choice and it sounds like
you're not looking for a new nose you're
just looking to shave the hump and I
think that your husband well it is your
body your choice so make the decision
that's best for you I think that when
your husband sees how little you've
actually changed yourself yeah he will
be like oh okay I remember when I first
was getting Botox and Zach was like no
plastic surgery literally I was like
shut up yeah I literally I don't
remember if I did wind up telling him I
was doing it but I also know I came home
that day and he didn't even [__] know
that there was something different with
me no men are obvious myopic surgery is
different than a nose job I mean surgery
is different than injectables and you
have to go under so you absolutely have
to tell him he's gonna pick you up yeah
yeah you need a ride
um but I think he'll be shocked at how
the same you look yeah but I'm really
here for it like your wedding is an
important day it's something that you've
said bothered you for years like your
whole life do it you're gonna like I'm
all for like taking control of the
things in your life that bother you
whatever it is I agree with that
oh my God it's so it's so freeing when
you realize like I don't have to accept
the things I don't like yeah and then
that's just like something that's just
taken off of your shoulders is something
that you're thinking about all the time
yeah
nice yeah I'm here for it great all
right hello Jackie oh and letertia I'm a
loyal gen Z toaster I came across one of
your viral tick tocks I've wanted to
send it into your toasters and I finally
have a reason to get some advice I'm a
21 year old college girl and I've been
dating a peach on Bryce for a year and a
half so sweet incredibly intelligent
yada yada
to put it simply he's 23 and balding
he's extremely in denial and has
convinced his hair is just he just has a
really defined widow's peak he will even
pull his hair back and go see my hair
goes all the way back and it makes a
triangle at my forehead one time when
trying to convince me he actually had a
Widow's Peak he Googled widow's peak and
sent me an article that literally proved
he had one it was actually an article
titled how to tell if yurido's Peak is a
receding hairline
I love this man tremendously and while
his hair doesn't affect my obsession
with him I'm beginning to notice it more
and more is it a big deal do I tell him
do I slip hair growth vitamins into his
drinks am I a horrible shallow person
for even thinking about this so much I
would love to support and help
for him and his hair growth Journey if
he wants that it is just is it just is
really noticeable to me and I hate that
he is living in such a state of denial
which is so jarring because he's so
smart thanks so much love you guys XOXO
a toaster with a balding boyfriend
this wouldn't bother me it wouldn't
bother me either but let me tell you how
men really are in denial about their
hair it's like women worry about so many
things like aging wrinkles saggy boobs
crow's feet and like men really have one
thing and it's their hair like if you
even bring it up there's so
[__] like defensive about it
like Ben has really thick hair and Ben's
dad Bruce has like a mop so bed has good
hits a lot of it is jeans but you know
sometimes I'm like Ben why don't you
like if I see like maybe like a little
thinning I'm like why don't you just
like start Rogaine like it's hurt yeah
it can why would you put chemicals into
your system if you don't have to Rogan
is a little thinning no but like Rogaine
is an extreme okay a vitamin something
like a neutral you can do yeah that's
better right I'm like why don't you just
start like you know it really can't hurt
preventative so defensive no but there
are things that cat like especially this
like you're talking about a little bit
of thinning this
um person is talking about like actual
balding like he could start Propecia
which can cause
also like a bald man like is a nice look
and if he does if it doesn't bother him
yet and he's like in denial like let him
live in his denial imagine there was
something like you were aging and like
you you weren't like phased about it but
Ben was like you have to get bow down no
wait okay
let's go back to the one previously
we're getting married you should shave
the hump off your nose
I think that this girl especially you
love him so much and it's like once you
fall in love with someone who cares what
they look what they look like anything
his balding hair he walks around with it
doesn't realize it'll Stave off other
girls like 100 what's the problem yeah
and he'll cut around to it when he when
it starts to bother him when he realizes
it if he wants to do something about it
there are obviously things that he could
do but he also doesn't have to do
anything about it
yeah he can also shave his head like the
thing with with men which is so
frustrating it's like the one thing they
struggle with is balding and like being
bald is also a look you know yeah they
made it into a look it's like women
we're worried about skin saggy and like
saggy skin doesn't become a look right
it's so unfair no it's it's so unfair
it's not something that would bother me
and you love him already like
Love is Blind once love is it's actually
not that's what we learned from no I
just I also want to say like I'm in love
and I'm not blind like if there's
something wrong nobody's friend lost his
hair it would literally not mean
anything to your relationship no not to
our relationship but he has an egghead I
think honestly Ben losing his hair would
be really bad but for him like he would
have to go through it like yeah it would
be emotional for him
he's emotional for me too I want him to
be happy right you would be but not
because of the loss of hair for you no I
wouldn't be unattracted to him no no
right yeah I think you could let this go
yeah you don't especially if it doesn't
bother him and you know if it's really
going as rapidly as you say it is he
will notice soon enough and he will
either take measures or decide to you
know live a bald life and this is really
A Hymn problem and something a journey
that he has to kind of Walk Alone yeah I
walk a lonely road
that's all I've ever known
okay ready for like the big deer
toasters update I'm ready so I have her
original submission here she was 36
years old she had two serious
relationships it didn't work out but she
had a really steady job in an apartment
and she was in this Crossroads because
she wanted to have a baby and she was
thinking more and more about doing it on
her own yes she wrote to us for advice
asking you know Jackie do you think you
could ever do it alone do you have any
friends who have done this
um but she wondered what we said and we
totally encouraged her yeah but we also
urge like caution because it's it's not
easy and takes a village do you have a
village but we also said you know if you
know you only have so much time as a
woman unfortunately and like if this is
something that's so important to you
do it so ready
hi Claudia and Jackie I'm writing with
an update from my dear toaster
submission I'm the 36 year old toaster
looking into single motherhood after
careful consideration I decided to go
with a single mother by choice root I
went to a fertility clinic I started
making the moves blood work ultrasounds
Etc one day in early December I was
online looking at sperm donors when I
heard Taylor Swift's lover playing on
the speaker outside my apartment I
opened the door and there's my
ex-boyfriend with a ring asking me to
marry him we had broken up a year ago
because he wasn't ready to get married
and I needed the commitment I was so
surprised and so happy fast forward a
few months we just found out a few weeks
ago that I'm pregnant I cry we must have
gotten pregnant right when we got back
together because I'm now 13 weeks along
I guess our favorite saying is true man
plans God laughs congrats to Jackie on
her second pregnancy I'm so happy that
we're on the same timeline I mean
it couldn't get better you couldn't
write it better than that I know oh my
God I'm obsessed
things happen I know and I feel like
this is proof that like when you
prioritize yourself and like you make
yourself happy and like you do what's
right for you like good things happen
yeah
like you don't seek validation in others
in relationships like you want something
you're doing it on your own like people
are attracted to that yeah I literally
got emotional reading me too I have full
body chills I'm so happy for you I'm so
happy for you this is the most amazing
outcome I didn't know that ex-boyfriends
just show up with a ring playing lover
you know what because she probably she
said I want a commitment and she bounced
for a whole ass year she let this man
spiral and he saw the best thing walk
out of his life
so much so that he ran and got a ring
you know we could learn a lot from this
girl she's a queen queen I'm so happy
for you Mazel Tov oh I'm so happy and
you're pregnant at the same time as
Jackie oh
let's chat let's chat so let's swap
stories the real moral here is when you
write into Deer toaster as good things
happen so that email account we do
weekly advice to your toasters at
gmail.com for your submissions try and
keep it brief you know need to know
details don't be writing an essay I
can't read that on here
um and it's always Anonymous so dear
toasters gmail.com thank you guys to
everyone who wrote in thank you Jax for
being you thank you Claude for being you
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories so you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places so
every listen to podcast find us the
toasty five star review about a
beautiful strong in and smart we are and
wickedly talented hope you guys have a
great day we'll see you tomorrow for
Thursday's episode love ya bye